yeah so we we've got a bunch of studies
stupid i mean this is this is a this is
a very common story that came out a year
ago a year before that white liberals
are more likely to mental uh a mental
health condition we've got this from
zach goldberg as a doctor or other
health care provider ever told you that
you have a mental health condition you
can see that among white liberals it's
substantially higher double just about
double that of what people who are a
very conservative report conservatives
have the least uh the lowest level now
what i've heard some people argue like i
mentioned on the liberals
they argue that this is because liberals
are more likely to go to doctors
there it's less stigmatized among the
left and i'm like for the sake of the
red flag laws let's just say that's true
wow could you imagine fascists
exploiting the fact that you want health
care to take away your guns when you
want to defend yourself from the
fascists personally i don't believe
that's true because that would imply
that people who are very conservative
far right are more likely to go to the
doctor than conservatives which makes no
sense and it also makes no sense that
someone who is liberal and someone who
is very liberal would have different
degrees of stigma of a stigmatized view
of getting mental health therapy i think
what you're saying there's some evidence
of what you're saying already which is
you find already again for the safe act
you found people who are literally
they you have find veteran veterans
affects veterans more than anybody else
veterans are more likely to have a
firearm than non-veterans and they're
also more likely to have some form of
invisible injury whether that's ptsd
traumatic range or something like that
that then non-veterans so you find that
a lot of veterans in their communities
will not go get help because they know
to your point in the second they have it
on their record
someone's taking their guns
and it's usually a family member who's
angry at them or sometimes a former
family member who's angry at them for an
ex a spouse a girlfriend who will not
take their gun away so yes it does
happen it's already happening in new
york state i was thinking of external
circumstances that can make people crazy
like new york city brake dust you know
there's brake dust in the atmosphere
from all these cars goods goes it's so
small particularly small that it goes
through the avioli in your lungs and
right into your blood stream which is
way worse than like smog hype causes
hypertension which can lead to stress
which can cause to mental disorders
which can cause to a doctor visit so
like what just because you live near a
toxic chemical plant you can't have a
you and you're more likely to go
neurotic means you're going to be less
likely to have a weapon i don't like
that did you know that there was a
correlation perhaps spurious uh between
leaded gasoline and crime rates and as
leaded gas lead started getting removed
from gas crime rates started to go down
uh some
i guess the speculation is as cars were
driving the lead was being you know
particularized or particulates were
going to the atmosphere people were
breathing it in it was poisoning them
and it was screwing with them it was
hurting their brains
so we got rid of that and then crime
went down i'm not saying it's a direct
causal you know effect cause and effect
it could be a spurious correlation but
the fact is i think you make a good
point
there was also a study on happiness that
found that people who are in closer who
are closer to nature
typically have higher rates of happiness
so imagine you live in a big concrete
block that smells like sour milk and
break pads
you know we went to new york i went to
new york when was it like a month ago
two months ago
man it stinks
it's crazy being out here in the middle
of nowhere and just all the different
smells and all the fresh air the trees
were surrounded by trees so it's all
just clean fresh air
and you go to the city and you're like
oh it's a unique wall but this is
exciting and i think that actually ties
into what we're saying about mental
health right so left-wing people tend to
be more likely to live in cities what do
you think is better for your mental
health
being packed into a small apartment
building like sardines and paying you
know two thousand dollars a month for
one bedroom and you're cramped
what should you live did i say 200 i'm
sorry i meant 2 000. i know i know i
meant 2 000. um no that's too low which
is probably like 3 000. i'm sorry i'm
sorry like eight thousand dollars thank
you there we go
there we go 8 000 they let you sleep in
the corner of the elevator exactly um
but none of these things are good for
your mental health that's a good point
and it's not just what i think it's like
andrew huberman's neuroscientist has
done experiments that gazing into the
horizon for 15 minutes a day and having
that depth perception greatly enhances
neurogenesis and you know is going to
allow you to to allow to not be
stressful to fix your brain
right oh it's funny to touch grass right
it's but it's true it works you go you
just go outside for a little while it
resets your brain i just love this when
people uh you know people post a meme
they'll like touch grass like you're too
online right and i'm just sitting there
like dude you are in a concrete cubicle
surrounded by concrete cubicles and i'm
looking at my window at a mountain and
trees in every direction and when i look
at when i look out the window you know i
see i see a groundhog we named him
winston and i see a bunch of rabbits
there's one rabbit that sits right in
front of the door he's not scared of us
at all nice and i'm like it's probably
not smart of that rabbit
what feed that dude but here's the thing
i'll tell you this
when every day you go out there's like a
fox running around and we're like he's
trying to go for the chickens we're
shaking our fists i saw a raccoon last
week we got wild turkeys
it's fun yeah they're hilarious yeah
when the turkeys walked over to the
chicken coop and the chicken started
losing their minds it was hilarious
i lived in new york man there's no magic
there it is it is anger animosity nobody
knows each other nobody likes each other
there's people fighting all the time are
you in the city in new york city right
now i am based in i live in queens have
you been there for a long time aoc is my
congressperson good for you i accept
your condolences
for perspective do you get out of the
city frequently of course i'm i campaign
i go upstate new york all the time yeah
i i live in western new york it's
because i'm i i go all over the place
i'm up a little western york is probably
our strongest place and the libertarian
movement is strongest in western new
york in fact one of the counties in 2018
i got nine percent of the vote in a
county and there's a couple precincts up
in north country where i got like 25
percent of the vote so north country is
pretty strong libertarian western new
york very strong libertarian um so yeah
we have a libertarian strongholds across
the state do you advise people to get
out of the city from time to time all
the time yes absolutely it's expensive i
know for your average you know maybe
lower middle class person to get up it's
like 40 what is it 40 bucks to take the
train up the grenade back the glory that
new york state actually is and and i
wish could be more you know our state's
a beautiful state there's everything you
can want in our state everything is from
madison square garden to niagara falls
to mountains and skiing to lakes to
fishing
to broadway to whatever is the thing you
like you can get it in new york state
the problem is our government is so
oppressive
that people can't stay here it actually
breaks up family is it because the state
itself it's like they're governing the
state as if it was new york city but
then the rest of the state's completely
different correct the this is my entire
issue right the point i bring up
constantly is a lot of things that
people are saying are true but they're
not gonna happen in new york state it's
simply not going to happen so my goal is
several fold one is to simply make it to
where
we have more localization that is not a
perfect answer it's just a better answer
let brooklyn be brooklyn and let ithaca
be ithaca and let broome county be
broome county let the north korea be
north country
let them be their own most people who
are in new york state who are not
democrats who are republicans
independents uh libertarians
conservatives they want one thing to be
left alone that's what they really want
leave me alone they don't care about
brooklyn they don't care about manhattan
just leave me alone as they want so my
goal is to achieve just that i do that
that's realistic it can happen it can
work but i'll i'll bring up a more
important piece of everything we talked
about
none of it is going to be a system never
gonna work none's gonna be fixed if we
don't have a third answer right now
everything becomes left versus writer us
versus them or whatever you decide and
the other person to your point earlier
is evil so i can do whatever i want to
hurt them or kill them there's got to be
a third entity i believe is libertarian
party i'm clearly biased and i say that
every time i am but it might be maybe
it's andrew yang's forward bar which is
why i made a connection with him maybe
it's that i don't care but i'm i think
it's mine i think it's my party but it's
got to be a movement yes that that
allows other people to talk to each
other without pointing a finger that
allows people to go you know what you do
you i do me we're good and right now it
doesn't exist so that's libertarians are
on the right culturally and why do you
say that
i mean it's just it's
in the culture war in the context if you
go to a leftist and say you're a
libertarian they will say your right
wing
i think i think that's often true
because many people who are re
republicans who
call themselves a battarians when
they're not but they're not they're not
libertarians though correct they're
not i mean i mean liberals and and the
establishment left and modern leftists
do not believe in libertarianism and i'm
talking about that in the philosophical
not the not the big libertarian party
i'm not sure where you're going you are
you're telling me that
are you telling me that culturally
people think we are on the right or are
you saying that libertarians are on the
right in the culture war the libertarian
party is
no different than conservatives
okay we are as a party we are far more
left-leaning socially than republicans
are sure far more and the culture works
heavily about social issues right so how
can you say we're right-leaning
when we
join the left in most of these things
like what what things did you join the
left-hand uh cannabis as an example
right drug war the right is all about
support the drug war cannabis is evil
the left is like cannabis is good and
libertarians are further than left and
yeah most democrats are like let's just
regulate and tax cannabis libertarians
are like let it all go
so it's definitely changing the
republican party though we're left when
it comes to
gay rights the the gender sexual
minority community we're far left on
that further than that trump was
gay marriage yes but you said
conservatives donald trump is right
right sometimes sometimes
the republican party then so
the republican party is viewed as as
right-wing libertarians are viewed right
alongside it viewed as i'm agreeing with
that but in reality
the issue is the point i'm making is
when i go and so first of all when
people try to accurately describe me and
i'm not talking what the media says they
say like libertarian center or like
libertarian liberal center stunningly
attractive stuff yeah
that
that's a fair assessment when i go and
talk to
progressives and leftists they say
conservative far right 100
we had vosh on the show and he called me
far right yep and so you mentioned a
space where you can bring people
together and it's like yeah but look
when we bring on these progressives they
outright tell us they disagree with what
you said they yes they should have a say
in other people's lives period i agree
so when you say most people want to be
left alone you're not talking about
bringing both sides together you're
talking about trying to appeal to to the
common person who wants to be left alone
yes that's that's what i'm saying yes
but you did you did like three different
things in there the first thing is if
you're saying am i viewed by most as
right wing that's true most people say
that most of the time my biggest issue i
have in in when i'm running for office
is the when the rights angry at me it
comes at me right the right will say
you're wrong because this and i love
that because i'm a master of judo so i
will take them and i will take their
attack and put them down i i can turn
people from the right fast and from the
left the left will simply ignore me they
will just ignore me not talk to me
dismiss me i need to draw which is why i
like guys like rosh because voshwa is
attack yeah right and i want p i like oh
debate bros i like destiny i like bosch
i like dylan burns because all those
guys are left but they will attack me
and i can have a conversation with them
so much that left will not even talk to
me and i beg i reach out and beg them to
talk to me and they just won't do it
you're correct but that's because they
believe
that i am right-wing even though i'm not
that's not neces it's not so much about
the fact that you're right-wing it's
that they have no argument
the people who have arguments will argue
the people who don't want and typically
among the left they don't have arguments
well but that doesn't that doesn't
answer what i was talking about right i
don't think that we are are rightlying
it at all i think we we only write
certain things but i don't think
libertarians actually are right and i
think the the culture believes we are
well when they talk to us they go oh and
why i said is because when i get people
from the left
to talk to me
they often stay
but i'm referring to they stay the
culture the cultural uh scale not the
the economic scale so right and left
mean very very very you have to define
what left and right means i'm using in
the context of if you were to walk into
a room full of people who listen to
podcasts left and right has a meaning
you are right wing
if you were to talk to someone about
social policy and economic policy you're
probably center or something that affect
but that's not relevant when you're
trying to get people into a room when
you have big media funding the
colloquial definitions of yeah than
writing valid means
that's what i mean to say you made the
point that you want to create a space
where you can bring everyone together
and it's like oh i love that idea but
like you said the left will not have
those conversations the only people we
get two kinds of people that want to
come on this show that are on the left
and i should say mostly grifters
who are trying to manipulate us and
exploit us to then turn around to their
fan base hoot and holler and then and
then screw us over right either not come
on the show cancel the last minute which
you've had many of or just start
tweeting bs accusing me of things that
never happened so they'll you know we'll
get them on the show and they'll say oh
tim did this and oh now oh geez and then
try and get press out of it we then have
people who have like no following they
have no body of work they're not very
active in politics they're just small
accounts that have maybe a couple
thousand followers right and they have
no strong arguments they want to come on
the show and you know what happens when
we invite these people on the show they
said they're dumbfounded confused having
no idea what to say i've had that same
issue right as i've tried to reach out
to the left more and more i brought
people up obviously i have a smaller
show but when i bring with my small show
i sometimes have an issue where my my
people get mad at me because i have to
use kid gloves
because if i don't use kid gloves i make
the guests look really bad good do it
and i don't want to make the guests look
really bags i'm trying to be i'm trying
to i want the left to come on my show
and if i beat them up too badly then
nobody comes back anymore so i have a
similar issue where sometimes i bring
someone on who is just they're so
accustomed to talking within their own
bubble
that everybody right is wrong that when
they call my show they're unprepared for
anything so i've got to use kid gloves
or make them look terrible this is why
you get people like jordan klepper who
go down to rallies to find the oldest
and most ignorant among the trump
supporters to make that the focal point
because when i think it was vish burra
actually met him on the show when he
actually talked to jordan clapper
clapper's like uh-oh it reminds me of
during occupy wall street when um
i forgot the dude's name he was uh
jessie lagreca shout out to jesse
lagreca he was being interviewed by
griff jenkins of fox news and he went on
this tirade about how fox was not going
to actually share what their real
opinions were and the video was secret
was being recorded by somebody else fox
never aired the interview and then the
left got a hold of it published it and
they were like this
fox won't tell you what the occupy wall
street people are actually concerned
about the funny thing is the things we
talk about the federal reserve freedom
liberty was exactly what was being
espoused by some of these people occupy
wall street although unfortunately
eventually i got taken over by social
justice leftists and then absolutely
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you